Do you live here?
Yeah.
Okay, we're really lost.
Where are you trying to go?
Museum, which I think is that way.
Am I right?
Yeah, it's definitely that way.
Okay.
Let me see here.
Alright, first of all, you're upside down.
Okay.
Okay, so yeah, we're way down here.
All right.
You want to be up here.
It's that way?
Right.
So you're going to head five blocks north.
When you get to Joey's Pizza, make a right.
Then you're gonna go three blocks east.
Okay.
There's a hot dog cart on this corner.
You're going to make a left of that hot dog cart...
...and you're going to go three blocks past this jazz club,...
...and it's going to be right in front of you.
Okay, great.
Okay, so I knew I was right about this.
So it's five, three, and three.
Yeah.
Great.
Thank you very much.
Oh, wait, let me get a picture of you guys.
Thank you so much.